[Music]
foreign
welcome back continuing our coverage of
the Johnny Depp Amber Heard definition
trial verdict after the jury was
released part of dev's legal team
Camille Vasquez and Benjamin Chu held a
very brief press conference in front of
the courthouse
the claims against Johnny Depp are
defamatory and unsupported by any
evidence we are grateful so grateful to
the jury for their careful deliberation
to the judge and the court staff who
have devoted an enormous amount of time
and resources towards this case
our judicial system is predicated on
each person's right to have his or her
case heard and we were honored truly
honored to assist Mr Depp in ensuring
that his case was fairly considered
throughout the trial
we are also most pleased that the trial
has resonated for so many people and the
public who value truth and Justice now
that the jury has reached its conclusive
verdict it's time to turn the page and
look to the future thank you all so much
and thanks to the jury thank you so much
Thursday morning herds attorney Elaine
Brendan Hoff appeared on The Today Show
for an exclusive interview she said
Depp's team demonized Amber Heard and
suppressed vital evidence to the case
the op-ed didn't even mention Mr Depp by
name and so what basically they did here
is demonize her and they did they were
able to suppress the the medical records
which were very very significant because
they showed a pattern back going all the
way back to 2012 of Amber reporting this
to her therapist for example we had
significant amount of text including
from Mr Depp's assistants saying when I
told him he kicked you he cried he is so
sorry that didn't come in is there any
other way to interpret this verdict
though that this jury for whatever
reason and I hear you on some of the
evidence that they didn't hear listening
to Amber Heard did not believe a single
word you know and that's because she was
demonized here a number of things were
allowed in this court that should not
have been allowed and it caused the jury
to be confused
yeah I'm sorry for the face she the
attorney seems as as convincing there as
she was on trial but let's let's push
forward Terry Brenda have indicated
Amber Heard could not pay the 15 million
dollars to debt so so what happens now
I was gonna say one of the things my law
school Professor used to say too bad so
sad get ready for the collection
attorneys I think he should push forward
make sure she pays that debt it is a
judgment against her and it's something
that will be collected if that's what
Depp wants and they can take liens out
on her wages they can you know make sure
that they do it over time so she can pay
they can schedule it and frankly it's
not 15 million we know it's 8 million
three hundred and fifty thousand I think
swedenhof said 15 because that was the
question but it's much less than that so
I think over time she can pay it and I
think she can try to raise the money
somehow you know through a GoFundMe but
either way I don't think he should
settle it for less than the Judgment
unless something as I mentioned before
like seven million maybe and that would
actually get him back to where he was
before the divorce he paid her that
amount give it back and maybe he could
even give it to a charity for guess what
domestic violence you know maybe he
gives it to ACLU and donates or pledges
or pledges or donates I don't know and
of course don't forget it's not 15
Terry's got the math perfectly there uh
and so that's how it's going to play out
Dr Tracy in her interview Brendan Hoff
also indicated Amber Heard plans to file
an appeal what would it take for her
case to move forward and what could it
look like
right now we're probably going to be
seeing a motion to set aside the verdict
if it hasn't already been filed both
sides can do that it would be set aside
based on the weight of the evidence and
I don't see that being granted after
that they have 30 days to file an appeal
in the Commonwealth of Virginia and then
a briefing schedule will be set out it's
a very long process to appeal it can
sometimes last up to a couple years
all right so like I said 30 days
8.35 million dollars I don't think
Johnny Depp and Amber Heard we're going
to hear the last of them just because of
this verdict the scenes are going to be
playing out for quite some time so thank
you both for the updates and the
breakdown that as well again not 15
million Terry Austin has the math it's
350 cap of the punitive you go down in
10 and then not I don't have so many
fingers but Terry's got the math correct
okay thank you for that Terry coming up
on lawn crime daily our comprehensive
coverage of the Johnny Depp Amber Heard
trial continues about Johnny Depp and
Amber Heard both reacted in the moment
of following the verdicts
[Music]
foreign
[Music]